[Musique]
c'est mon père
je me souvienne de lui de quelqu'un qui
était très aisément
mes enfants encore quelque chose de lui
mais je sais pas où il est
le 30 novembre 1957 j'avais septembre
mon père a été pris à 5 heures du matin
on n'avait pas le droit de sortir de la
chambre on était resté dans nos lits 8h
9h toujours rien parvenu 10h et puis ma
mère nous envoie en ville et nous dit
bon bah écoutez allez voir vos oncles et
dites leur que votre père est sorti ce
matin 6 heures avec des policiers en
civil qui le connaissait surtout qu'il
le connaissait mais il est toujours pas
de retour et ce qu'ils savent quelque
chose on avait été voir un de mes oncles
qui nous avait dit ah bah écoute et il
n'est pas seul ils sont 17 à la même
heure
c'était pour un contrôle et puis plus
rien
plus rien plus rien plus rien
on a vécu des années très très difficile
surtout enfants
moi j'avais 7 ans j'avais des filles qui
me disait ah oui mais moi aussi mon père
il a été mis en prison il est resté de
gb tu l'as toujours ton père
même s'il est resté cinq ans même s'il
est resté dix on tue lacunes peut-être
vous paraît à moi alors qu'ils me
disaient oui mon père il a été tué par
l'ouest dans la rue oui mais tu l'as vu
mort qu'il a vu enterré ce que tu peux
pas te comparer c'est pas la même chose
on se pose des questions il est on il
est où ce american je sais qui reviendra
jamais ça m'est égal dans fun day il est
où
depuis longtemps on savait que c'était
arrivé à des milliers d'algériens mais
on ne connaissait guère qu'une seule
histoire véritablement c'est celle de
maurice audin les militaires le savez
ces colonisés algérien qui n'était pas
comme maurice audin des européens ayant
des relations des relais d'opinion en
métropole personne ne les contraigne
passerait par pertes et profits grâce à
une archive que j'ai découverte aux
archives nationales d'outre-mer en 2018
on a eu la possibilité d'enquêter sur un
certain nombre de cas un gros millier de
gens dans ton c'est parce que les
familles les ont recherché auprès de la
préfecture d'alger quelles ont été
enlevés par l'armée on utilise le terme
d' enlèvement de remarquer pas
d'arrestation parce que ça ne ressemble
en rien à une arrestation
ordinaire quand vous savez qu'à tout
moment
peuvent débouler chez vous des
parachutistes peuvent venir vous prendre
vous emporter dans un lieu secret faire
de vous ce qu'ils veulent donc y compris
vous torturer on le sait très vite que
la torture est systématique et vous
assassinez et bien par par capillarité
par par diffusion
c'est toute la population visée
potentiellement viser c'est à dire toute
la population qu'on appelait musulmane
d'alger qui a peur
ici on a les derniers cas documentés
donc les derniers cas pour lesquels on a
ajouté de la documentation et on se rend
compte du coût que c'est des sommes
parfois très jeune le plus jeune
le très jeune elle est en photo ap ap
n'en peut plus de 5 ans donc lui c'est
le plus jeune de tous il a été enlevé le
14 juin 1957 on continue de chercher on
continue à évaluer documents par
documents et informations par
informations avec le risque que dans
beaucoup de cas on n'avance pas sur la
connaissance précise de chaque cas
mais avec l'idée que en avançant on va
mieux connaître le déroulement collectif
le déroulement pour l'ensemble dans
certains cas on arrive finalement un peu
à ce qui est déjà la connaissance de la
famille c'est à dire londres toute
vraisemblance la personne est morte sous
la torture où elle a été assassiné son
corps a été camouflés où son corps a été
détruite mais ça ne va pas nous indiquer
ce qui compterait vraiment beaucoup pour
la famille et qui serait de savoir
exactement où comment qu'est ce qu'on a
fait en réalité du corps de la personne
[Musique]
je m'appelle waouh ça vire là il s'agit
donc qu'il recherche qui concerne moment
que joie au rabais a enlevé en 1958 avec
plusieurs autres personnes par l'armée
française je suis très ému alors que je
l' ai jamais connu c'est parce que j'ai
vu en fait
alors tendu weppler de mon père quand il
regardait un peu le le portrait de mon
oncle en dix ans
puis parti tu m'as laissé tout seul même
si totalité des années je pense que mon
père a beaucoup souffert après
l'indépendance il a beaucoup beaucoup
chercher son frère et à chaque fois
qu'on me disait qu'il y avait un
charnier quelques pas donc dans
notamment à l'est du côté des aurès si
tout ça on l'appelait pour à
l'identifier l'éventuelle dépouille de
sens dessous
demande pas de
depardon et tous ces trucs là ça c'est
pas important qu'est ce que ça va nous
rapporter tout ce que je demande c'est
vraiment où est la dépouille oui où il a
été mis il a été enterré où il a été
jeté j'en sais rien c'est tout
j'espère pouvoir vraiment pour moi un
jour me dire voilà j'ai réussi à trouver
où se trouve mon oncle où il est enterré
sinon je transmettrai à des enfants à
mes neveux et nièces qui peut-être un
jour reprendre et le flambeau mais au
moins moi je n'aurais pas avancer comme
je pouvais
[Musique]
où
don
il
[Musique]